you you asked for this [ __ ] no I didn't
but you just quit whining like a [ __ ]
you not whining like a [ __ ] like a
[ __ ] you like to cram like ten years of
pitch into one day I'm not sure how to
define it but I was doing it an
interview with Mindy Kaling for a
charity and she said to me it seems to
be in all your movies there's a
character who's stuck and I had never
thought about it feeling exactly that
way before but then I realized that
she's right you could say that about the
40 old version you could say that about
feet in the king of Staten Island and
maybe that's what I'm exploring meeting
people who would mean something to
happen to them maybe to make them hit
bottom so that they can learn the lesson
the manor they didn't need to learn to
evolve in some way and now usually when
things fall apart it's funny I don't
know why but life falling apart is
usually funny
[Music]
[Laughter]
when we did the 40 Oldenburg's and we
were looking for somebody who could play
the chest waxer
who was a professional waxer so we're
going we need an actress who knows how
to do this but also knows how to act and
somebody said this is the person I don't
even know if we did a real audition
maybe just a try we just tried to get a
sense if they knew how to act at all and
the particular woman who claimed to know
how to act
I think lied I think she lied about it
she came in and she put the wax over
Steve's
nipple and we don't look lost the nipple
that's all I want to say about it I
still don't want to get in trouble or
not hiring a properly credentialed waxer
but it was a dangerous day we almost
hurt Steve when we were going to wags
Steve I was thinking about when I was a
kid we used to go to this plane called
action park and we'd read these little
cars on these cement pad and most people
would fall off and you would slide down
this event and you'd get this terrible
burn that would take skin off of your
your arm and you go to the nurse and
they would always put some something on
it so it wouldn't get infected and
whatever that was really hurt and then
people would scream and curse at the
nurse every person would walk up there
and she picked up on and then they would
curse her out and that's what I
explained misty needed to happen so we
wrote a bunch of Harris's Seth Rogen I
think was the lead curse creator and
then he wrote up a big sheet of curses
and
some point someone said we needed a
clean thing from the yell just in case
this is too dirty or maybe for
television screenings of it but we can't
curse and on that list they wrote Kelly
Clarkson we're not sure why it's funny
15 years later she remains a gigantic
star and I think where are you babies
come from where do you think they come
from well I think stork he um he drops
it down and then a hole goes in your
body
and there's blood everywhere coming out
of your head and then you push your
belly button and then your butt falls
off and then you hold your butt and you
have to dig if you find a little baby
that's exactly right
when we cut the breakfast scene for not
you know we wanted it to be a bit of a
walk of shame moment and Seth comes over
and everyone is very uncomfortable and
the kids start asking questions so I had
bought and hires in the scene with Seth
and Katherine and Paul a lesson and how
I did that is I just didn't feed them
for a few hours and then I would you
know strap them into chairs and then
suddenly give bacon to them and then as
everyone had the conversation where does
a pole or trying to learn a little bit
about who Seth is and it's really
uncomfortable my kids are just chime in
they kind of forgot there were cameras
and they just started talking and asking
questions and that's why there's that
naturalism because everybody is
improvising around the fact that my kids
are just eating bacon like it's any
other day
I would like to rear up and jackknife my
legs and kick you both in the [ __ ]
jaw with my foot bone that's what I
would [ __ ] love when we did this
scene and the principal's office what
happened was Leslie yells at this kid
that she's furious at and then that kid
tells his mom and then the mom gets
yelled at by Paul and he just goes off
on her and then they get called him in
principal's office and the joke was that
in the principal's office
both Leslie and Paul just lie and at
that point in the movie they're not
talking they're having terrible fights
but in this moment with the principal
they just instinctively support each
other by lying and the line drives
melissa mccarthy crazy and we knew the
list of mccarthy be hilarious because we
just worked with her in bridesmaids so
in the moment when she finally snaps
back I'm Leslie and Paul we really did
just let it go I'm gonna slit somebody
open like a fish and drink their blood
that's what I'm gonna drink if we don't
start getting to the [ __ ] point here
probably I'm gonna start with Karen
Carpenter's head I'm gonna rip her head
off and I'm gonna drink her blood and
she made everyone laugh so hard that was
one of the most glorious times on a sad
day I've ever seen and Paul Leslie could
not contain themselves that's why during
the credits we showed some of it because
it was just just such a joyous day we
wanted the audience to be able to share
that and then I'm gonna come back and
light you on fire I'm gonna light you
all on fire but I'm going to start with
you Jill I'm gonna [ __ ] torch you you
know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna go buy
a [ __ ] pickup truck and a quarter
rope and I'm gonna string around all
three your [ __ ] necks and then drive
around town dragging you that's what I'm
gonna [ __ ] do that's completely
uncalled for
really Jill you think it is most of that
red she came up with we also had Paul of
Hell on set who was one of the legendary
Saturday
live riders and amazing actress and she
was feeding some of those lines to
Melissa as well and Joanne Marin who is
a great actress and his Leslie's acting
teacher who she went to acting school
she went to her acting school played the
principal and her reactions are just so
funny and in the scene Melissa McCarthy
makes fun of her haircut her bob and
it's vicious and the funny part to us
was that was just Joanne's haircut go
suck a big [ __ ] dick Jill that's
totally uncalled for
[ __ ] [ __ ] everybody hates you ate
your [ __ ] Bob that wasn't funny for
the movie that was just her current Bob
and at some point mr. McCarthy says I
hate that [ __ ] Bob and that made us
laugh you're a terrible liar
nothing's going on around here it's
completely innocent the scene outside
where Leslie goes off on Eric Bana
because she becomes aware that he's
cheating it's one of my favorite scenes
because Leslie gets to do something in
it which is my favorite thing bad accent
you know that's always really funny
because she's hilarious when she can't
get an accent right that always cracked
us up and in this scene she's so angry
and she's mocking Eric Bana and
she starts saying you just want to get a
Robin tag people go to massage parlors
that doesn't mean I was getting a
rub-and-tug
and it doesn't sound like an Australian
accent I don't even know what it sounds
like it's like white English or Scottish
or the combination I think at some point
said says what is that Jamaican accent
and you're watching her fun in all
afternoon was endlessly funny
you turn on a TV in a given Sunday when
the Super Bowl and drive off in a
Hyundai she's supposed to get the shorty
Tyco with your money did she went to the
doctor got lipo with your money what are
you talking about they'll hate her and I
met with LeBron James to try to talk him
into doing the movie he just had a great
time hosting Saturday Night Live and I
think he really liked the bill and he
got a kick out of our basic joke which
was that he would play builds best
friend and it was just a funny thing
that his best friend happens to be
LeBron James and when the first scene
that we thought of was a scene where
they're just talking about his
relationship and they're playing
basketball while doing it and the joke
is that bills terrible and the run is
going at him at 10 that even as friends
he's not taking it easy on bill and it
just really made us laugh shooting it
and even when we thought about it we
were like this is gonna be so funny
watching the run dunk on him and be very
physical and hurt him and that is
exactly what LeBron James did at the
ending scene when they're talking about
his relationship with Amy he starts
giving advice and slowly Bill Hader
realizes that it's the lyrics to a Kanye
West song it's gold digger and he was so
funny
doing it so deadpan and we were even
annoyed by it because we want comedy we
don't want the basketball legends it'd
also be good at what we do like who are
happy even great but we're also like you
have to be as good as us and what we do
also being a family it's fine if you
don't have kids cuz you don't know if
you're gonna come home and
and your kids are [ __ ] up you make
everyone around you feel crazy people
are normal then they hang out with you
and then that [ __ ] Jack Nicholson in
the shining or something
my mommy tried to drown me [ __ ] ground
pool you're like [ __ ] eight feet tall
one of my favorite scenes from the king
of that island is when bill burns
character and Pete Davidson's character
you know who having gotten along for the
whole movie suddenly break into a really
sloppy fistfight and in the middle of it
bill tosses Pete into an above-ground
pool and there was a joke that they
improvised that became I think the
biggest laughs and the movie is Pete
starts calling him a gambling addict and
he improvises who bets on the Jets and
built immediately comes back and he says
they're gonna come back they're gonna
come back they got a traffic and that
became the biggest laughs in the movie
it was so in the moment that it was you
know I guess ridiculous because are the
Jets really gonna come back I don't
matter the Jets and that's such a line
that we get a laugh that you know just
saying they're gonna come back it's
funny
so I also put that to them
[Music]
my email led to me what the [ __ ] is that
guy right there
why don't believe my favorite cameo of
all time was when Eminem was in Funny
People because we just loved him so much
you know he's the greatest of all time
to us and he showed up and we had to
like riff with him and we were like
scared about how to do the jokes with
him
and we didn't know him really I think
Adam had maybe had some brief
interactions with him at some point
quickly we realized that he didn't know
who Ray Romano plus and on the spot we
were like okay I think this is the scene
that you know he's complaining about how
hard his life is the Adam Sandler and
then he thinks he sees Ray Romano take
his picture I just started screaming at
Ray Romano threatening him hey ray hello
Marshall [ __ ] problem here buddy
would you like to [ __ ] me is that what
this is would you like me to [ __ ]
bend over for you right now no it was so
funny to watch but then in between takes
Ray Romano turns to me and he says why
is it so funny that he yells at me like
is it funny that you guys think I can
touch myself what is the joke here and
it's hysterical he's a very very funny
guy and then Adam went outside with him
and Eminem played and unreleased songs
from his next album and I was so jealous
that they did ask me to go outside and
listen to the songs also and I'll never
forgive Adam for not making sure I also
got to go in the car
[Music]
you